hey dr. Wallach are you doing okay in
your heart in your heart our legs okay
okay baby had any surgeries any hay
surgery is sins on itself
oh I got one here okay one cent okay any
other issues any diabetes have a
pressure arthritis I'm sorry say again I
got high blood pressures okay all right
sure
um what do you weigh sir I'll weigh 280
I'm about five four five four two eighty
two eight zero
yep okay five I'd like to see it
I'd like to see away 280 and I'd like to
see you away at 5-4 I like to see you
weigh 135 140 is he need lose 140 pounds
charmagne what would you do for this
gentleman here Michael and what what
other issue did you say he had besides
he had high blood pressure and he has
since installed in his heart he's got
obesity okay
personally for those issues I would give
him or you guys sleep apnea to sleep but
there is no such thing as sleep apnea
that's the way people go ahead okay well
he needs he really should have three
healthy brain and heart packs however
money is probably a problem so I would
get him at least two okay any high blood
pressure I would as well for other
issues I would add ultimate daily
classic and for the overweight he can
take the rev and it should work okay
yeah and none of the bad stuff no fried
foods and processed meats no oils or
glutens we'd run around oats
ideally char said three healthy heart
attacks a month two full dose at
breakfast lunch it there if you have to
drop back to - it'd be a full dose of
breakfast and dinner I wouldn't go any
lower than that
rev I get two bottles a month saying
take a dropper flow under your tongue
thirty minutes for each meal and then a
second proper pull out of your tongue 15
this works medium absorb your old
tissues Musharraf said to support
healthy blood pressure
the blood flows through blocked arteries
you're going to cover two areas here the
ultimate daily classic tablets I go
ahead because your body and everything
I'd get three bottles a month
the ultimate daily tablets they can take
12 of those a day for breakfast for
lunch for dinner time and let's see here
yeah let's go with all that I think
you're going to find that you're going
to sleep better you're losing a half a
pound of two pounds a day and you know
take your blood pressure
take your blood for yourself don't run
the doctors offices run up a bill learn
how to take your own blood pressure zzg
to get a machine or one of these hand
driven of blood pressure kits but so
they do have these little electronic
things now you can just tie to your arm
your blood pressure blood sugar and all
that stuff but um we want to see your
blood pressure drop into the normal
range we want to see your weight drop a
half a pound of two pounds and we want
to see circulation going through the
coronary arteries and actually reduce
the risk of I throw one more thing what
would you throw in charmaine that'll
help dilate the Carnera arteries
bluegrass niacin plus would help nice
and plus yeah and you go ahead and get
two bottles of the niacin plus per month
and him take two of those tablets twice
a day that's going to increase blood
flow and also reduce the risk of blood
clots